I'm going to run through a fairly long
presentation to introduce the subject
and basically as you know this is
basically a discussion on the ongoing
crisis and looking at perspectives both
from the North and the South if I may I
think it's it's useful for us to
remember that that that the crisis is
not something which completely came out
of nowhere many people had warned that
crisis was building up there was a great
deal of concern about the clearly
unsustainable global imbalances which
preceded the crisis not unlike the
global imbalances which preceded the end
of Bretton Woods system in 1971 and the
plaza arrangement of 1985 also there has
been as you all know a very serious
problem in the absence of any real
international financial system to speak
of in after 1971 my old professor Robert
riffin suggested that we are living in
assists in a nonce with a non system and
I think despite Bill Clinton's promise
in 1998 to have a new international
financial architecture there really was
no system to succeed there but also very
importantly I think we all know that the
last two and a half of three decades has
was dominated by an ideology of
deregulation of self-regulation and
liberalisation including capital account
liberalization and they were very
important cheerleaders of processes of
what might be termed financial
globalization although there was
evidence from the outset that financial
globalization either contributed to
growth and in fact exacerbated
instability and
another important point which I think
needs to be made and why this discussion
has chosen to focus on perspectives from
the self is that by and large developing
countries where the emerging markets or
non emerging markets have been rather
innocent victims in this in this crisis
and they have suffered EE because not
only have they been innocent victims
they have also been constrained from
acting in a more bold way in response to
the crisis both by the ideology as well
as the policies which have been pursued
by certain powerful institutions finally
I think there has been as you all know a
very important shift away from the old
g7 arrangements in favour of the g20
type arrangement switch at this at the
face of it seems much more inclusive but
one should emphasize that it really
keeps out 171 other countries which are
part of the international community and
for which the g20 suddenly feels no real
serious accountability and the attempts
by the United Nations to try to
influence the course of events largely
under the initiative of the 63rd
President General Assembly father miguel
de scotto in appointing professor
stiglitz as chair of a commission to
look at the problems which have killed
Bryce through crisis and its impact
basically have been rather modest the
impact of the commission's report has
been rather modest we have seen very
little serious consideration in among
the powers that be of the major
suggestions for reform but perhaps it's
a question of timing we until fairly
recently for example there was very very
little effort to try to transform
financial regulation in the centres of
of Finance London and
and in this country but things seem to
be changing Tim be at least in the form
of Paul Volcker is now more prominent
but it remains to be seen whether scene
where the team C will actually make an
appearance at all but that I think may
be wishful thinking but let me quickly
run through a number of slides give you
a sense of the global imbalances as you
can see from this the global imbalances
really grow pretty much from the middle
of the deck of the past decade and
although the United States runs a huge
deficit the main surpluses are actually
run by the oil exporters contrary to the
impression Paul Krugman might might give
you that it is basically China which is
the root of all evil and all and it's
important also to recognize that the
imbalances have come down with the
slowing down of the economy for rather
obvious reasons but here again you get a
sense of that the size of the u.s.
deficit and the relative size of the
surpluses run by different countries and
what is very apparent here is that China
begins to run a surplus with the rest of
the world fairly recently from the
middle of the decade and not really
before that because although it's
running a huge surplus with the US it's
actually running a significant deficit
with many developing countries now the
promise of financial globalization was
that you know capital would flow from
the capital rich to the capital poor
instead as you can see from this half
the capital flows actually to the United
States and developing countries account
for less than a fifth of the capital
inflows now us macro financial policies
particularly of the last decade but
arguably even before that as suggested
by Joe Stiglitz us booked on the roaring
90s actually is really part of the
problem and
and and I've already mentioned the
problems of the non system the kind of
mac macroeconomic policies which are
pursued particularly during the bush
period and then you have the problems of
increasingly lacks financial regulation
and it's important to recognize that
much of the deregulation of Finance the
end of glass-steagall for example
actually did take place under Democratic
administrations as well now the savings
low savings rate is something which
everybody knows about and then you have
the problem of us consumption and the
kind of hubris accompanying the growth
of the financial sector in both the US
and the UK to give you a sense of the
fragility of the system and I think this
inverted pyramid gives you a sense of
the kind of rigidity of the system which
was facilitated by this phenomenon which
is often referred to as financial
deepening and as Paul Volcker suggested
more recently they probably the only
significant find useful financial
innovation is probably the introduction
of the ATM and even that has you know
does not actually and added any value
per se and he among others have pointed
out that you know financial deepening
really did not add any real value to now
this graph this bar charts basically
give you a sense that although we often
think of globalization as involving
trade integration in fact the growth of
financial integration as represented by
the upper blue line has been far greater
than the growth of trade of trade
integration is represented by the lower
red line and despite greater
cross-border flows of finance especially
since the mid since the 1990s we find
that real investments or what economy is
called gross fixed capital formation has
hardly increase in fact it's actually
trended slightly downwards now financial
globalization has resulted as i pointed
out suggested earlier in a net flow of
funds from the south to the north what
Lucas referred to as capital flowing
uphill the this only becomes a problem
because of the predictions of
neoclassical economics in expecting
capital to flow in from the rich to the
poor and the contrary is actually taken
place the cost of funds has not actually
declined because of the because of
greater inter mediate inand D and the
group and and the concentration of all
of oligopoly stick power which has
enabled OECD rents financial rents to
significantly increase in particularly
in the OECD economy since the 1970s
there has also been greater volatility
as well as lower growth and higher
instability this gives you a sense of
the flow of funds from the south to the
north the blue line sort of sums it up
for the developing countries the dark
blue line now the short-term flows have
been especially problematic they do not
contribute either to investment or the
real growth they often contribute to
asset price bubbles and consumption
binges and and and and as Justin Lin has
pointed out sometimes they contribute to
over investment which poses a serious
problem for us today as we try to get
out of this crisis the fact that there
is considerable overcapacity becomes an
impediment to encouraging new
investments in this situation and this
is subject which I suspect will
preoccupy us in this discussion now
moving quickly I think if I may sum up
the arguments made so far we have a non
system we have double standards in the
international international economic
governance we have a problem of
inadequate and inappropriate regulation
and we have a failure of international
cooperation now the financial impacts on
developing countries of this crisis have
been
been buried we know that stock markets
in emerging markets have collapse much
more we know also know that reversal
capital flows FBI has also been
adversely affected and we know that
borrowing costs have gone up especially
in among so-called emerging markets and
financial positions dip going into the
crisis particularly in East Asia and
Latin America was stronger because of
the build-up foreign reserves which is
also of course as you are known part of
the problem now reserves have rapidly
evaporated with the X with the collapse
of exports particularly in 2008 and 2009
and fiscal space has also been very
limited and constrained this basically
gives you a sense that although
borrowing costs have come down slightly
they have significantly higher than they
used to be we do know about the spread
of contagion I want to dwell on this
they are you know many vectors to
consider and we also know how all this
has contributed to what is essentially a
deflationary spiral and again I won't
elaborate on this one important
difference between the current situation
and and and the situation in the late
1970s is the fact that although there
was speculation in the West in the
industrial wastes in Latin America and
in East Asia there was actually very
rapid growth during the late 1970s
thanks to the availability of cheap
petrol dollars no internet at low
interest and so on so forth what we have
this time round however is a situation
that thanks to globalization a much more
integrated international economy and
and and and the fates of economy is much
more closely tied up than before now
prospects for this year are uncertain
but I think optimistic scenario would
suggest a growth of slightly over two
percent at the world level now most
developed economies have seemed to be
coming out of the recession since the
second half of last year and we also see
some hopes of some kind of recovery in
so-called transition economies and
developing countries as well you see
some slight improvement expected during
2010 now at least 60 developing
countries who adversely affected last
year experiencing contractions and in
total including developed countries and
econ economies over a hundred economies
experienced contractions last year now
the economies in transition were
initially expected to do much worse than
the developed economies but as it turns
out developed economies generally did
much much worse now with in developing
economies and in the least developed
countries although they didn't move into
negative territory the fact that you
have higher population growth generally
speaking in those economies basically
means that on a per capita basis they
could be much worse off now we also know
that oil prices have come down that food
prices have come down as well since the
peak in early two thousand eight but
they remain higher than they were in the
printer then they were in the preceding
period World Trade did collapse
significantly over ten percent in 2009
and there is a general consensus on the
estimates of the trade collapse now as
you can see the
the exports from developing countries
fell much more than exports from the
oecd economies and the prices of
minerals oil as well as metals have
declined although they begin began to
pick up a little bit now to summarize
the trail impacts basically we see that
exports have declined the terms of trade
have moved against primary exporters
particularly and its surplus trade
surpluses and reserves have run down
pretty quickly the only silver lining is
lower energy as well as food prices now
for the least developed countries the
whole question of aid flows has been
notoriously unreliable and just to give
you a sense of the international
commitment to do to addressing Africa
you can barely see the sliver of Oda to
Africa on the right-hand side of about
26 billion and just contrast that with
the almost 20 trillion which has gone
into fiscal a fiscal stimulus as well as
other recovery efforts now my only point
really is that the ODA figures are often
quite misleading because of the high
interest payments which many developing
countries have to make on on on
ostensibly discounted loans so that
although the Democratic Republic of
Congo is supposed to have received
almost five and a half billion in Oda
into 2003 they actually only received
about 400 million in net in actual
transfers another significant difference
between this crisis and the earlier
regional crisis in Asia for example is
that remittances have been also very
adversely affected and part of the
reason of course is that in the migrant
workers in host countries have
experienced significant drops now the
social impacts are still very difficult
to measure there
all kinds of figures which have been
been been touted and perhaps given that
the depths of the collapse last year was
not as deep as initially feared perhaps
the the figures are not as dire as
originally forecast by for the ILO for
instance now the point I want to make
with this bar charts is to make is that
it's extremely important that countries
be able to respond to downturns in a
timely way and the fact that you have a
delay for example of three months can
often lead to a delay in terms of the
impact of the stimulus measures which
which might take well over a year and a
half according to the Isles estimates
now this I think is significant because
develop developing countries were
basically deterred by the IMF from
undertaking more robust recovery efforts
earlier now the fact the failure of
international cooperation is another
major problem and as we we have done our
own modeling exercise here and we argue
that if we had a much more coordinated
effort in response to the crisis we
would have a stronger and a more robust
recovery which would have actually me
put everybody would actually benefit
from that developed countries as well as
developing countries as well as
transition economies now a major
consideration going into this crisis and
obviously recognized by many governments
and now is that while output recovery
can often be
it can often take less than a year in
the 1991 downturn as well as a 2001
downturn dairy cow output recovery took
basically about three quarters but the
job market recovery Oh employment
recovery took two and a half years in
the case of the 91 downturn and took
almost four years in the case of the
2001 downturn so it remains to be seen
how long job recovery is going to take
this particular downton and this of
course is a matter of grave concern
especially for those who I worsley
affected now the International responses
have not been have not been as robust as
i would have liked and the although the
the shift of of leadership from the g7
to the g20 may have had some positive
effects it remain it remains to be seen
the failure to act on some of the more
of the stronger recommendations for
response is a matter of some concern and
disappointment and the last line last
bullet point here basically underscores
that the june 2009 effort at the united
nations basically did not have really
much of an impact largely due to the
indifference of the major economies and
the leadership of the major economies in
the world now I want to contrast this
with what happened in two thousand in
1944 that 1944 the Bretton Woods moment
is very significant in my view because
it were represents and recognition by
Roosevelt of the signal of the need to
move away from the League of Nations
type of framework and took and he as you
know convened what was called a united
nations conference on monetary and
financial affairs although in the United
Nations had not come into existence and
did not come into existence until a year
later and it was very much a u.s.
initiative at that time whereas
Churchill took the view that there was
no need to have any
multilateral meeting it was enough for
the US and the UK to come to some kind
of understanding as to the shape of
international monetary and financial
affairs and as you also know at Bretton
Woods it was envisaged that you would
have basically three prongs of a
post-war international economic
governance involving the fund the World
Bank and very importantly an
international trade organisation which
unfortunately the US Congress vetoed and
so the promise of the habana charter of
1948 was not really met now the Bretton
Woods was not just about monetary and
financial stability it was also about
creating the conditions for growth as
well as employment creation and very
importantly of course post-war
reconstruction reconstruction as well as
post-colonial development in contrast if
you look at the g20 meetings Washington
London as well as Pittsburgh they pale
in comparison with what was achieved in
bretton woods and I think it is
important to recognize that the stiglitz
Commission did make a number of
recommendations which would go some way
to meeting the promise of Bretton Woods
if the problem is a Burton was supposed
to be realized in the current period now
just let me conclude by suggesting that
while while I suggested rather
pessimistic scenario I think it's very
important to recognize that that that is
not all over yet and given the turn of
events in this country in recent months
and given the the continued persistence
of the crisis and given the possibility
of a double-dip scenario it is quite
possible that things may change the
strength of the recovery in the larger
developing countries China Brazil India
and so on may also mean shift in the
balance of the affairs which may well
have fairly significant consequences on
a range of runs so thought any further
ado let me now invite our three other
panelists to come up and invite Justin
Lin to the podium to address us Justin
Lin is the cheapest Joe provide Justin
Lin is the chief economist at the World
Bank and he he didn't directly succeed
Joe Stiglitz but Joe Stiglitz occupied
the position the second half of the 19th
1990s so Justin without any further ado
can I invite you to come in dress us
thank
well thank you very much Gemma just gave
a very comprehensive overview about the
causes of this global crisis the current
situation and us alone and so my talk
will focus on three points the first one
actually with hits you that the recovery
is quite Elijah and the second one I'd
like to argue that we need to continue
some kind of governments dip in earnest
by the conventional kenjan type of
stimulus will not work we need to look
beyond the conventional wisdom attention
stimulus and a third one we need to have
global coordination and cooperation and
if we can have this kind of global
coordination and cooperation we may turn
the crisis into an opportunity for more
sustainable and inclusive globalization
regarding the flexibility of this
recovery we know recovery was many
driven by two forces one was fiscal
stimulus adopted by the major country so
far and the second one was because of
the restocking commentary and abide that
according to our forecast last year the
global gdp contracted 2.2% and this year
is likely to grow 2.7% in a tray last
year contracted 14.4 percent and this
year is likely to grow four point three
percent however the main challenges in
the coming months and years is something
geometers mention excess capacity in a
real sectors
and according to the data in spite of
this recovery due to the restocking
inventory in a fiscal stimulus in
high-income countries especially in
January this year its capacity
utilization rate was there about 14.5
percent lower lambda labour achieved in
2008 the situation in developing country
was much better in a poor some country
like China its capacity utilization rate
or is a label integer production was
already exceeding the label in 2008 and
we know that with large underutilization
of capacity the new year's act is we
have some kind of dunwall pressure
because with large underutilization of
capacity certainly the unemployment will
be you know maintaining a high level and
under the canal situation certainly
hurts consumer confidence and also with
large excess capacities it will be very
hard for the private sectors to find
good investment opportunities and that
means even the interest rate it's driven
down to almost zero but private
investment business competence well
still be very long and under the kind of
situation we are going to see a very
brave low recovery and if we also put a
pressure on the financial sectors well
you know last year there was near were a
hundred of what he bangs in the US you
know collapse and according to a reason
FDIC report about seven hundred and a
two banks in the US are in the watching
test in some kind of dangerous position
so because of the restocking a human
Tori those kind of forced you know
welcome to an N or already come to an
end and the fiscal stimulus and it's
likely to lose skankin esteem so with
these kind of scenarios I think a double
tilt it's a real possibilities a double
dip it's a real possibility in under
this kind of situation how can the
government cope with that first I'd like
to say monetary policy may not work
because you use the monetary policy the
best you can do is to treatment to try
the interest rate down to zero and now
is the case but if you don't have good
investment opportunity people when our
response if you do not have good jobs
security people we're not increased the
SSF in their consumption also and it
also is going to hurt the developing
country because low interest rate most
likely is going to encourage you carry
trade short on capital afro through the
emerging markets and put a pressure on
the exchange rate as well as you know
the bubbles in the equity market or real
estate market and so a better way might
be continued to use the fiscal stimulus
increase the government spending but to
continue government stimulus there are
two issues that in people's mind the
first one is a sharp increase in a
public debts and according to some
studies show among the high income
country of g20 by the time or 2014 layer
public debt it's going to reach about a
hundred and twenty percent of their gdp
and a people you know at order for about
the sustainability of this hype
public debt in the other concern is a
so-called Ricardian equivalence the
government can use that financial to
increase its spending but people may
anticipate in a future they need to pay
back the debt and under the concern they
will increase their saving and as a
result the net increase in the demon
would be quite small and in our so that
won't be able to digest assault the
large excess capacity situation
certainly it's a theoretical possibility
and we do find some empirical evidence
to support for example in the 1990s
Japan encountered similar situation as
we encountered now and starting from 91
to 2002 Japanese government was very
aggressive in use fiscal stimulus and
its debt increased from sixty percent of
GDP in nineteen ninety one to one
hundred and forty percent of GDP in 2002
in activity in LA Superior that you know
it was a lost decade to Japan and the
main reason was because at a time the
Japanese government and I use a lot of
use a lot of fiscal stimulus but people
increase saving however i like to say
the reason that high debt level is a
concern as well as the reason why
Ricardian equivalence is a possibility
it's because other investment did not
increase the productivity of the economy
and we allow increase in a productivity
of the economy certainly the people were
clear that they need to pay back the
debt in the futures and start with
saving and the evidence is done you know
a friend of mine in Japan in the 1990s
told me that he stay in Japan for four
years and addy
row in front of his apartment was thick
out paved take out in a paper sex time
in four years and there was a
conventional condition type of viscous
demeanors certainly it was not effective
it could not increase the productivity s
and as how that that kick accumulated
and a gtp in a remember a in a stockage
but we do also find some other way to
make this kind of its stimulus much more
effective for example in the issue of
east asian financial crisis china also
encountered a similar situation and
there was a depression there was a huge
under traditional capacity in a starting
from 1998 2002 chinese government also
used fiscal stimulus to boost the demand
but most of those fiscal stimulus was
used to make investment in
infrastructure which was the button egg
or challenge groups until give one
example was a highway system in 1997
1997 the highway system in china was
four thousand and seven hundred
kilometres in a starting from 2019 98 to
2002 lost five years the highway system
increased five times in china from four
thousand seven hundred kilometers to 25
thousand one hundred kilometres in those
kind of investment certainly inertial
run create a job but more importantly in
the wrong one it boosts the growth
potential from 1979 to 2002 the average
annual growth rate of chinese economy
was nine point six percent per years and
at a time most people argue it was
impossible China to maintain was kind of
in a nine percent and pass gross weight
anymore is already 23 years in Japan
Korea and a song in the past year only
meant he knows kind of gross rate for 20
years
but after 2003 to 2008 no six years the
average annual growth rate in China did
not decline not only so increase to ten
point eight percent it was at 1.2
percentage increase in the gross weight
and the possibility was because of the
growth bottleneck has been released by
the investment during this fiscal
stimulus appearance and also as a result
the government that is a percentage of
GDP before the east asian financial
crisis was about twenty percent of GDP
and increased up to about twenty thirty
three percent of GDP in 2002 and after
that because of economic growth rate
increased so the dead ratio also dropped
down to now about twenty percent and
this is one example and I neglect like
we can also find out the example Korea
this time also encountered similar
prices and a Korea also was quite
aggressive in uses its fiscal stimulus
you use about two percent oh it's a GDP
and eighty percent all those gdp was
used in a green economy as a result in a
past two years Korea created about
200,000 jobs and a korea's gdp growth
rate this year is like to be about 4.4%
among the highest in the OECD country
and again because the lowest kind of
green investment released Koreans a
bottleneck across improve its energy
efficiency and so on so from this kind
of experiences we find we need to
continue the government support in order
to prevent the visual psycho autumn
operation but we need to make this kind
of investment in area which enhance
productivity that's my second message in
a for the global economy for the hong
kong country well if they want to
continue the stimulus
certainly the green economy is in areas
that they can consider however for the
high income country only greens
t---minus may not be largely not to help
the country in high income group to get
out of this you know crisis and so we
need to have a global cooperation in the
developing country to participate in
this kind of global effort for the
developing country they have a lot of
bottleneck for growth both in the energy
efficiency environmental issue and more
importantly in their infrastructure
their pata Negra growth in a further
developing countries like China India
not emerging market certainly they were
have enough resources was their foreign
reserve or physical space to engage in
fiscal stimulus but for many our daily
working country especially long term
country they are constrained by their
fiscal space and also their access to
foreign wizard they will not be able to
participate so under this kind of
situation hanggan country they have her
currency they could use a test financial
but they don't have good opportunity for
investment the warping country they have
good opportunity for investment which
can enhance the productivity those kind
of project cancer ticketed can make in a
written to do we pay not an investment
in the future but they are constrained
by the parameter so under this
consideration I think we can have a
global solution find a way to channel
some fun from the heineken country will
be the rich country to make investment
in the developing country it will be a
win-win situation however this kind of
possibility need to overcome to issue
the first one is our coordination
coordination issue because if only one
high income country well one reserve
each country you know do this kind of
cross borders stimulus
we're not a huge lucky effect so the
individual country will not have the
incentive to do that any other people
work for you right to overcome the free
writing problem we need to have a global
coordination in ascending one is that
even we have this one we also need to
have good mechanism for implementation
and i hope the g20 can pray this
function for coordination come up with
this concept discard this / this
proposal and make it is is an agenda
energy donkeys for the coordination in a
secondly for the implementation luckily
we have the Bretton Woods system now the
war Bank the regionally World Bank they
are minted to carry all those kind of
projects and that's one of the members
up in a tree Hubble's kind of
institution so if we can work through
this kind of institution then maybe with
the fun and we'll whisk good investment
we can get out of this global crisis in
a sustainable way at the same time with
this kind of investment in a developing
country the a growth potential will be
increased or being enhanced and then the
globalization up to the crisis will be
more inclusive
Thank You Justin I fail to introduce
Justin Justin was trained at the Taiwan
national university also at Beijing
University and at the University of
Chicago and is responsible for setting
up the China Economic Research Center
among various achievements before being
appointed as chief economist of the of
the bank he has recently defined his
analytical position as neoclassical
structureless position I'm not quite
sure what that means our next two
speakers have both Kane's ians and
albeit slightly different persuasions in
terms of being from different sides of
the Atlantic our next speakers Probert
Pattnaik who's probably also in my view
the leading marxist economies working in
the world today he's written on a wide
variety of subjects including
macroeconomic issues and and his
professor and java lal nehru university
besides being nice chairman of the
Kerala State Planning Commission
thank you very much Jomo Joe Justin
trends it's a pleasure to be here and a
privilege to be part of this very
distinguished panel I'd like to thank
the Heyman center and the Committee on
global thought for giving me this
opportunity I'd like to discuss the
whole question of crisis in a somewhat
historical context typically when we
discuss the crisis we concentrate on a
limited range of events over a limited
period of time occurring in a limited
region typically the formation and the
collapse of the housing boom in the
United States during the current century
but in a sense I think this crisis has
to be located within a somewhat deeper
context and the reason is the following
that in any capitalist economy where you
have asset markets obviously these
markets tend to be people by speculators
who are driven not so much by prospects
of earnings from the assets as by
prospects of capital gains as a result
you tend to have bubbles because people
buy in order to sell the assets the day
after tomorrow which tends to build up
bubbles and the bubbles have the impact
of actually generating a boom likewise
the collapse of the bubbles creates a
crisis but these booms and crises
themselves are really superimposed on
deeper phenomena as a matter of fact in
a period when you have a secular upward
trend for reasons which have to do with
underlying stimulii to the growth
process in the capitalist system you
find typically that the crisis would be
shallow they would be brief in fact that
is the way that the underlying upward
movement is something that makes itself
felt so whether the crisis is going to
be deep and shallow or whether it's
going sorry is a security shallow and
brief or it is going to be deep and
protracted it some
that really depends upon factors which
themselves do not have anything to do
with that particular crisis but have to
do with rather deeper long-term
tendencies underlying the movement of
the system at the time now in periods in
which these deeper underlying tendencies
causing an upward movement are not there
in other words in periods when there is
no kind of sustained up turn for other
stimuli typically the crisis result in
great depressions the Great Depression
of 1930s in my view was really one such
period when one burst of upward movement
had come to an end the stimuli
underlying that had finished while no
new stimuli had been found so we had a
protracted period of the Great
Depression and I'd like to argue that at
the moment we are also in such a period
because of which I believe that no
matter what the short-term movements of
gene GDP and so on even the current
crisis is likely to be a fairly
protracted one if we look at the period
of the Great Depression let's just go
back very briefly and then X curses into
history where we look at the period
before the First World War the entire
period from middle of the 19th century
right until the First World War was a
period of remarkable and pronounced boom
in the world capitalist economy this
boom was sustained by an international
arrangement which was underpinned by
colonialism and that arrangement
basically consisted in the following
Britain which was a leading capitalist
country of that time had an enormous
current account deficit vasavi Europe
and the temperate regions of European
settlement like the United States
because of which as it were they found
markets in Britain Britain sustain this
current account deficit by running a
current account surplus we survey the
tropical colonies and that current
account surplus we survey the tropical
colonies was in fact made possible not
because the colonies were
being fast on the contrary they are
stagnant or retrogressive but at the
expense of displacing local production
what is called the process of
deindustrialization getting rid of older
craftsmen older production specially in
industries like textiles the tropical
colonies in turn had in fact current
account surpluses visa V Europe and the
the temperate regions of European
settlement so you had written balancing
her trade via the colonies and this
being made possible because the colonial
market according to the British
historian s be sold was on tap you could
actually simply push your goods there at
the expense of the artisans and so on
not only was the balance of payments
actually sustained this way the British
balance payments leading capitalist
country of that time but what is more
Britain actually made substantial
capital exports to the temperate regions
of European settlement not because it
had a current account surplus we
surveyed them as I said his massive
deficit but because the colonies had a
current account surplus for which they
did not get any credit which was
actually taken away by Britain through a
process of what is called the drain that
the Indian nationalist Karl Marx himself
kept talking about which was a
unilateral appropriation of surplus
because of the colonial status of these
countries there for the entire
arrangement was something which was
pinned down by the colonial system now
this could not go on forever because
obviously there are limited their limits
to the extent to which the colonial
market can be penetrated if there's a
stagnant markets and secondly you had a
situation where the Asian tropical
markets were increasingly loss to
Britain because Japan came in and
thirdly you had of course in the post
First World War period a deeper gradient
crisis preceding the Great Depression
which has Kingdom burgesses was because
of the fact that the wartime excess
demand for agricultural commodities was
changed into a post-war regime of excess
supplies of agricultural commodities
bringing about an agricultural price
crash in 1936 which therefore meant that
the sole colonial Macon
did not work as well as it had done
earlier canes Alvin Hanson and others
have referred to the Great Depression as
arising because of the closing of the
frontier that the that the sole business
of exporting people and capital from
Europe to the temperate regions of
European settlement is something that
really came to an end but on the other
hand even if the frontier had not been
closed the means to get to the frontier
via the colonies had got closed in the
post-second World War period therefore
on the basis of Keynes you had an
alternative stimulus which was suggested
which of course was state intervention
in demand management but of course an
under pressure from financial interests
who never liked the state to play any
active role other than in their own
interests you had a situation where
typically state intervention in demand
management has progressively been
whittled down until of course it had
there some revival in the context of the
current crisis because of which you find
that from around the middle of the 1970s
the growth rate of the advanced
capitalist countries has in a secular
sense become lower than it was in the
post-war period so-called golden age and
what is more even this growth rate has
been sustained by periodic bubbles with
a dot-com bubble a housing bubble or
something and the collapse of the bubble
is now landed us in a situation where
all the earlier stimuli are over and
nothing new is immediately on the
horizon of course revival of the role of
the state once more as a provider of
demand not just as it were interfering
briefly but once more as as a sustained
provider of demand can revive a growth
process again can provide a new and
sustained stimulus but there are
problems to this that matter I mean the
first obvious problem of course is that
this entails overcoming the opposition
of financial interests but even that is
not enough in other words even if it is
the case that the fiscal deficit could
be sustained could be
dude there are two additional problems
which actually define the current
situation the first of these is that
liberalisation of trade has basically
meant that in a certain sense wages in
the advanced countries including in the
United States are now no longer
independent of the fact of the
substantial labor reserves that exists
in the world economy in the developing
countries because if it is the case that
such labor reserves exist then of course
labor from the advanced countries is
competing against the low-wage labor
from the developing countries because of
which unlike in the old days when the
following happened namely productivity
would rise the rise in productivity in
the metropolitan country in the advanced
countries would be accompanied by arise
in the wage rate now you have a
situation where productivity increases
in the metropolis are not necessarily
accompanied by anything like
corresponding increases in the wage rate
because the wage rate get tied to the
fact of the wage rates prevailing in the
developing countries which in turn
remained low because of the existence of
substantial labor reserves as a result
is a tendency towards under consumption
those of you who be familiar with this
terminology there's a tendency towards
under consumption of the bran and sleazy
kind in the world economy to overcome
which it is not just enough that fiscal
deficits be there but fiscal deficits
would have to increase and would have to
be sustained now for an individual
country like the United States to be
doing so is obviously becomes to that
extent far more difficult this something
which would really require coordination
at in German refer to the coordinated
fiscal stimulus to require coordination
across the number of capitalist
countries the second problem which
arises is as Jomo's diagram showed that
even in the midst of the current crisis
food prices remain extraordinarily high
they have come down briefly compared to
the peak they had touched in 2008 but
nonetheless they remain extraordinarily
high and of course much higher than the
were two or three or four years ago now
to the extent that is the case any
revival of the world economy if it is
not accompanied by a substantial
increase in food grain production is
going to give rise to very serious
inflation in these essential commodities
if you look at the per capita world for
drain output that has been declining
declining in absolute terms over the
last decade or two to two-and-a-half
decades or so from the middle of the
1980s many reasons for it but one very
important reason of course is the the
the weakening of the position of peasant
agriculture all over the world under the
impact of neoliberal economic policies
in the delicious period the state
everywhere including in developing
countries like India supported sustained
promoted protected peasant agriculture
but increasingly this has been given up
leaving peasant agriculture to the
mercies of the world market fluctuations
on the world market and incursions by
metropolitan capital multinational
corporations agribusiness and so on as
it results the decimation of peasant
agriculture and I use the term advisedly
because in India itself 200,000 peasants
have committed suicide the decimation of
peasant agriculture has had the impact
also of keeping food drain growth rate
extraordinarily low if that happens then
of course a revival of the world economy
in terms of demand at this time a food
drain output does not pick up is
something which should give rise to
inflation to rely on this inflation
causing an increase in food ringrose
rate because the peasants benefit from
from high prices is unrealistic because
the impact of high food prices does not
translate itself into higher incomes as
far as the peasant second son supposing
we had in other words the argument I'm
putting forward I can restate this way
supposing we actually had a world state
not the US state or British state of the
Indian Chinese state if you had a world
state then the world state could in fact
have provided
munis to the world economy and could
have done so by spending more protecting
promoting peasant agriculture in the
world as a whole so that together with
demand food output would have been
increased unfortunately we don't have a
world state but such a world state if we
had would of course have to be something
other than an imperial state that is
backed up or is interested in promoting
the interests of enhance capital but it
would have to be a Democratic world
state that genuinely looks after
promoting and protecting peasant
agriculture promoting and protecting if
you like the world's countryside we
don't have that but on the other hand
obviously the requirements of the of
overcoming this crisis under store the
necessity not only of confronting
finance capital and as it were
re-enacting a scene in which the state
once more has a certain degree of
responsibility in providing the stimulus
to brutes but the state itself is one
which has to be as it were coordinated
with other states and would have to be
informed by the outlook of promoting and
protecting the conditions of peasant
agriculture as opposed to promoting and
you know underwriting the interests of
agribusiness multinational capital in
the agricultural arena what is required
in other words is a global arrangement
which actually is vastly different from
the one which is currently existent
presided over by globalized finance
capital the transition from this to that
is not easy but the crisis underscores
the necessity of this transition thank
thank you very much Robert our fourth
and final speaker really notes it needs
no introduction to a Columbia audience
nonetheless I am very tempted to pay
homage to the late Paul Samuelson who
repeatedly said that he had found his
rafa when Joe Stiglitz publishes
collected scientific papers Paul
Samuelson as you know was the doyen of
off of the neoclassical synthesis in
this country and passed away late last
year and Joe Stiglitz was one of his
star students and publishes collected
papers so refer for those of you who may
not be familiar who collected published
papers of David Ricardo over a century
about over a century almost a century
and a half after Ricardo had passed away
and so Samuelson was rather pleased that
they collected scientific papers was
published in his own lifetime Joe
Stiglitz okay I think I'll stay here at
the table so we can move on to the
discussion afterwards let me just divide
my remarks into a first a brief
discussion on on how the developing
countries have been hurt very badly and
then secondly a few remarks about where
the global economy is going including
the impacts in developing countries and
then a third very few remarks about how
the nature the crisis in capitalism the
developing countries is Jomo very very
well pointed out have been in a sense
the innocent victims of the crisis and
this is very different from most of the
other crises of which there have been
met very many in the last 30 years where
which began in the developing countries
and
the worry was that they would spread and
become global the international
community at very great expense to the
developing countries managed the way
through these crises so that none of
them became a global crisis though 97 98
crisis was called a global crisis but
did not seriously impact the developed
countries but the wrong inference was
made from that experience the inference
was made that the economic system was
self-correcting and I'll come back to
that and that that it actually
reinforced the belief that the models
that gang Jomo referred to of
liberalization were working because life
in the defense industrial countries
continued almost unaffected but this
crisis was one that began in the
developed countries in the United States
and then spread to the rest of the world
and they were hit through all the
channels that were described through
Trey through finance through remittances
through foreign aid what made this
particularly difficult though for
developing countries was that the
instruments the risa the resources that
they had to deal with the crises were
much more constrained than those in the
developed countries the developed
countries responded to this crisis in a
way that was totally different from the
way that IMF told the countries in East
Asia to respond to the crises 12 years
earlier in that crisis the I am after
the US Treasury told the developing
countries raise your interest rates cut
back your expenditures and don't bail
out your banks and of course in this
crisis we bailed out the banks
we lowered interest rates to essentially
zero and we ran very large deficits but
the developing countries in this crisis
for the most part did not have the
resources there were a few that had a
large surpluses a large reserves like
China and they were the best students of
Keynesian economics and they they they
were able they succeeded in keeping
their economies economy going but many
of the other countries could not did not
have the resources to do it and there
was a concern as a result that the
downturn in the developing countries
would be much more severe and that was a
where in the figure that faith in the
slide that oak jomo said the IMF funds
were increased by New sdre allocations
of 250 billion dollars there are a whole
set of variety of programs that that
gave the IMF more resources but
interestingly relatively little of this
money actually went to the developing
countries and the developing countries
went through a slowdown but seemed to be
recovering particularly the emerging
markets India and China have recovered
with much less damage than I think a lot
of us anticipated the question was why
was that before answering that I want to
make one comment about in those
countries where there was a necessity of
turning to the IMF the IMF's position in
most of those countries was markedly
different from that that we've been
pursued in previous crises not only the
97 98
East Asia crisis but also Latin America
and Russia Oh crises all over the world
for the first time the IMF actually
changed its economic philosophy to be a
much more if you want to briefly to be
much more Keynesian they recognized that
they have been wrong in having or some
of the people particularly the head of
the IMF recognized that had been wrong
to have procyclical policies that had
counter-cyclical policies for the first
time they became very explicit that the
way they would measure when it was time
to withdraw was when employment was
restored to normal and they openly
talked about the need to maintain the
stimulus some long as one could until
employment got recovered in the case of
a few of the programs like Iceland the
programs were not only very expected
more expansionary allowing the countries
around very large deficits but they also
allowed Iceland to impose capital
controls which was had been almost an NF
mou to the IMF so it was really a very
mark changed in most of the policies the
one exception at the other extreme was
mafia which where where the downturn in
the GDP I think is one of the worst of
the world has ever seen in at least in
recent years like downturn is
twenty-five percent I think
probably know the numbers and the IMF
has been cheering it on saying that they
have to cut budgets more and restricted
exactly sort of interesting that that
that well they've changed their policies
in most countries there is this one one
exception well it is a little bit
interesting that the developing
countries have not been devastated for
the most part to the extent that was
anticipated I think one of the reasons
for this is that especially China
engaged in very strong policies of
stimulus and it grow slow from thirteen
percent to around nine percent but that
was still very strong growth and that
maintained the relatively strong
commodity prices and the many other
countries that were buying commodities
were thereby helped India has also done
in some ways much better than was
anticipated both of these countries are
countries where there are large
potentials for domestic economic growth
huge markets within their own country
and that is one of the questions going
forward about China particularly right
now and a postponed coming to that until
i come to the the discussion of global
imbalances at the end because China is
at the center of that discussion but I
think it is interesting that at this
juncture the developing countries
particularly in Asia are doing
reasonably well and that in
the economies of Europe and United
States are not doing so well so there's
been a kind of decoupling and the
question that is being asked now is this
can this be sustained is this just a
temporary thing or is it a more
permanent feature and i'll come back to
make a few remarks about that let me
talk about now some of the reasons that
i feel relatively pessimistic about
where the global economy is going and it
focuses on mostly the developed
countries but a little bit on the
developing countries the first is
something that the UN Commission
emphasized which is in a world of
globalization what matters is global
aggregate demand and global aggregate
demand is in very bad shape you can put
the issue in two different ways one of
them is what exists ainda global economy
before the crisis was America's
consumption that was Excel forted by
this high level by the housing boom the
housing bubble and now the bubble is
broken that won't be possible in savings
genetics takes is increase from 0 to 25
percent I'll come back to the attempt by
governments to fill in the gap but
there's another way of seeing my global
aggregate demand is likely to be weak
going forward one of the mass to do with
the fact that profit emphasized the fact
that the growing inequality in the world
and a very standard Keynesian argument I
think has a great deal of validity that
the marginal propensity to consume the
fraction of the income that
that lower-income people consume is much
higher than that of upper income and so
we just when we distribute income from
rich to the poor total consumption a man
goes down and this increase inequality
is going on in most countries of the
world the United States was one of the
countries that had as have very large
increases in equality in the United
States we said to people whose income
was going down or stagnating don't let
it bother you keep consuming as if your
income was going up and of course the
way they did that is through debt and
the reason they could do that it was
because of the sort of housing prices so
their their net worth looked like it was
good but it was phony and that debt
sustained consumption is not going to be
feasible going forward so that's one
problem inequality not in all the
discussion of going forward from the
crisis very little discussion about that
inequality and how that can be rectified
and therefore the the problem that that
poses for go black hooded man remains
remains the second reason that there is
a weakness of global aggregate demand
that the Commission the UN Commission
emphasized was a demand for reserves
that was related in part to the crisis
of 97 98 where the country's learned
what happened if you don't have enough
reserves one of the countries that what
crisis the prime minister told me you
know he was in the class of 97 he
learned what happened
if you did not have enough reserves the
IMF came in and took away your economic
sovereignty and then put push policies
that led to deep recessions and
depressions and so they and many other
countries around the world start
accumulating reserves the problem with
human wedding reserves is that is money
that's not spent and so there's a
deficiency in global aggregate demand
and the magnitude of this in the decade
and the last decade it has been enormous
it's in the now in the trillions of
dollars this precautionary demand for
savings of global reserves is only part
of the story there are other parts
having to do with export-led growth
having to do with the ability to pursue
export-led growth through industrial
policy being undermined by the WTO and
therefore putting more of the burden of
export-led growth to exchange rate which
means when you use exchange rate
policies it gets reflected in for an
exchange reserve build up the point I'm
making here is that there had been
export-led growth models for decades
without reserve surpluses being filled
up and the question is why did that
change one possible explanation is the
WTO the next part of it but the part I'm
focusing on right now are the
precautionary demand why is that
important because countries have learned
that those countries that had large
reserves did better in this crisis than
those that didn't because it enabled
them to have Keynesian policies to have
expansionary policies so the worry is
that there will be an increase in demand
for reserves and the insufficiency of
aggregate demand related to reach
we'll get worse the IMF has realized
this and in the meeting in Istanbul last
October they echoed the notion that a
key part of a dealing with the problem
of global reserves is to reduce the
demand for the build-up of research key
part of the problem doing with global
imbalances to reduce the demand for
reserves by providing alternative
methods of insurance then self-insurance
reserves our view of form of self
insurance they said well people won't
have to build up the reserves if they
have other ways of providing insurance
and the IMF offered themselves as the
way of doing that they would provide a
security blanket for all the countries
of the world unfortunately most of other
countries of the world said we don't
trust you they they said in fact an
effect they said we may like Dominique
strauss-kahn but the fact that he could
change the IMF so quickly means that the
next guy could switch it back and if we
get rid of our reserves in four years
time how do we know that the IMF will be
the same nice consumer friendly IMF and
not go back to the IMF that everybody
had loved so much before in the 90s so
the general sense is that the build-up
of reserves is not going to diminish may
actually accelerate at one of the
outcomes of the crisis now that's one of
the reasons for the pessimism the second
is the reason it's already been
mentioned by several people that what
had filled in the gap for a while was
government stimulus packages but those
are coming to an end and the willingness
and ability of governments to renew it
is diminished because
to the huge increase in deficits and
national debts I don't think this is a
good argument but the financial sector
which was very short-sighted in causing
the crisis has now become short sighted
in saying that we should not have a
stimulus and they have been drumming up
the view that what i call deficit
fetishism very strong view that the
government's cannot have should not have
deficits the point was made I think by
several the speakers that in fact if
governments spend money for investments
in fact all it requires is investments
with returns of about five or six
percent and the long-term national debt
will be lower than it would be if the
government did not spend the money so
the deficit fetishism is really bad
economics but the bank's financial
sector bad economics is what God is in
the crisis and they are now dominating
the political process the likelihood
that the United States will have a
second stimulus of a significant amount
is very low and in Europe it's even
worse they're beginning contractionary
measures in Spain in Ireland in Greece
Portugal and so they are going back to
Hoover right policies and prospects I
think are very bad the third problem is
again related to the financial sector
they are now beginning to reemphasize
their standard line that the underlying
problem is wage rigidity that if only
workers took a further wage then
everything will be fine the problem of
unemployment is too high wages and you
saw a front-page article
in the Wall Street Journal describing
this today as fact that what workers
need to do is to take a further wage cut
which would lower aggregate demand they
don't that's not the way they put it but
but that would they believe would solve
the problem so if that happens of course
aggregate demand will be further lowered
and the problems worsened so the
automatic stabilizers worked in this
recession in fact about seven eighths of
all the stimulus came from automatic
stabilizers and what the financial
market now wants to do is to
short-circuit those automatic
stabilizers I don't know whether it's
extent to which that will work but it
will the the downward pressure on wages
is exerting a depressing effect on the
economy the fourth problem the reason of
pessimism is everybody began this Christ
as saying we have to be wary of
protectionism and we all know what
happened after the leaders of the g20
said that we would not read not engage
in protectionism within three months 17
of the 20 countries had engaged in
protectionism America being among them
with the Buy America provision in the
stimulus package but I still think that
actually the protectionism was muted it
was a lot of it was it was outrageous
but it was muted and that was partly
because of the WTO but now that monetary
measures have come to an end fiscally
measures have come to an end that leads
but one instrument left and next
protectionism and the United States is
now getting prepared I think for a trade
war with China the rhetoric it just came
back from China very very intense
about exchange rate manipulation the fat
the Treasury has to make decision very
shortly about whether China is an
exchange rate manipulator and the
betting is fifty-fifty with that it will
do that and that that clearly is is
clouding the sky finally let me make a
couple remarks about global imbalances
that have been referred to a number of
times as part of the crisis today and
going forward let me make clear well a
lot of people talk about the global
imbalances they did not cause this
crisis I don't think they contribute it
even to the crisis in a significant way
the crisis was caused by America's
financial markets not doing their job in
this bubble them but i do think
imbalances are important i think they
there is a real worry about disorderly
unwinding of the global imbalances and i
do think that there is a very
significant risk they will cause the
next crisis within the next few years so
i think it is important for something to
be done and it's related to the problem
of protectionism because the u.s. sees
the the deficit trade deficit and that
is part of the jet forces generating
demand I think demand for protectionism
I think g20 discussions of coordination
are going to go nowhere I mean I I've
heard these discussions of coordination
as far as I can see there has been no
effective coordination almost ever and
it's not going to you know they're there
there's they're there they will talk but
the best that can be said about the
crisis response to the crisis it was a
little bit like side by side play each
of the countries went to the meeting
saying this is what we're going to do
when they left the meeting doing what
they said they were going to do
and as far as i can tell i think there
was no change in policy by any country
as a result of the meeting maybe i'm
wrong but it certainly not a very large
response but the global where the global
imbalance discussion is taking place
today is that there is a lot of pressure
with agreement in pittsburgh was that US
would save more and china would save
less now the US has actually reduced the
savings not increased its a because that
is to say what happened is household
savings went up but government savings
went down and more than offset the
increase so the accents that if we were
a full employment the global imbalances
would be worse but on the China side
savings hasn't changed but the remedy I
think is wrong I think the problem with
the world global economy is not that
there's too little savings but that the
save too much savings but the savings
weren't directed at the right place and
so the real challenge this really was
what Justin was saying is really one of
redeploying the savings internationally
it needs we don't dealt with the
problems of poverty and the third world
and global warming globally and within
China there's a need to rather than
using the savings for excess capacity in
the way China has very big challenges of
urbanization of health investments in
education technology so in general while
I think there should be some increasing
savings in China the main thing should
be a redeployment of the savings into
more constructive investments rather
than the excess capacity finally let me
say I think well we've talked about this
as an economic crisis it is a crisis in
capitalism the basic model capitalism
was that it's a economy
which was self adjusting marking
self-adjust we've had we know that that
was not true that as I say we've had
crises over and over again in the
history of capitalism the only period in
which there was not a crisis what's a
30-year period after the Great
Depression when we put in place good
regulations regulations can work so the
quite so the markets are not self
adjusting but we haven't really fully
taken aboard what that applies for the
working of the market economy so that's
so far in the United States there has
not been any or in Europe a significant
change in the model of the economy at
least in Europe there is a lot of
discussion of a new capitalist model in
the United States the strongest
discussion is maybe a little change in
the plumbing no change in a view of the
economic system but from the analytic
point of view the theoretical point of
view there remains some difficult
questions and maybe just throw throw
throw this out partly debt start the
discussion the standard general
equilibrium model talks about eventually
demand equal supply markets work not
just fast enough and the kind of
historical analysis the proper made was
really quite apart from that kind of
market processes and so one of the
questions is you know that kind of
historical analysis it provides that an
interesting description of what has
happened but I think that has to be
brought together with the discussion of
what why is it that the market processes
which are supposed to eliminate X esta
Matic supply he was supposed to bring
markets into equilibrium why which part
of that isn't working and why why aren't
they working and from the policy
perspective what do we have to do to to
get the
me not only back on track but prevent
another recurring the final general
point is that I shared the pessimism and
that I think Joe expressed the beginning
that we're likely in for a very long
period of a Japanese malaise which will
be of the form that we aren't in a deep
depression of the kind of the 30s but
neither will we be in a robust economic
growth thank you very much Joe we have
some time for discussion I would like to
remind you that this event is being
recorded and so please use the
microphones when you would like when you
make comments or raise questions there
are microphones on in both aisles
hey um I have a question for professor
pat knife I guess it could your dad
identify yourself my name is Lakshman
Gopal I'm in student at the school of
general studies I wanted to know we've
been talking a lot about the current
economic crisis and we've been talking
about the difference in the impact
between how the economies of the West
have suffered and how the economies of
the East have not suffered as much I
think back I've spent 15 years in this
country I spent five years in India and
I think back to the time when I think
the whale bank was trying to convince
all developing countries to use DDT and
pesticides in order to expand and
improve on their crop in crop intake and
now 10 years later as an adult I see
suddenly we're all green and we're
trying to were trying to get rid of
pesticides were trying to go organic and
we've seen the heirs of the earlier
policies and I see this in so many
different arenas where they're suddenly
these big girls who speak about all
sorts of different magical solutions but
it seems to me that especially given the
recent economic solution isn't it time
that in we we channel our own sort of
channel our own internal experience and
come up with different solutions i think
professors people that's what Stieglitz
was talking about how we need to ask
questions about the system of capitalism
itself and and try to figure out where
the problem is and find the solutions
but I mean shouldn't we really be
examining history and trying to see what
we can do in terms of at least for the
East maybe not for the West new
solutions because capitalism like
professors people it says is constantly
in crisis thank you yes please oh this
this is for my name is Jonathan Hogstedt
I go to Columbia School of International
and public affairs I was surprised to
see that you called attention to the
excess excess capacity
but then the solution was investment in
productivity and and that seems to be
getting away from the the idea that we
have a consumption problem that stems
from a distribution problem and this
this seems to underlie a lot of the
logic that that goes behind world bank
policies and I'm thinking about
agricultural policies mainly and and and
one example would be the privatization
of irrigation services and the
Philippines which are for small rice
farmers that the idea is you increase
production by injecting some capital
into the into the into irrigation but
you lose you that doesn't take into
account the power relations between the
owners of the means of production of
being the irrigation service and and the
small farmer which is going to
drastically affect the distribution and
the amount of the surplus product that
the farmer is going to get to keep
eventually how would you address this
logic in the context of this crisis in
the context of the ongoing food crisis
mix please my name is Elton and I go to
sepa my question is it seems that in the
last hundred years the US has been the
locomotive of the world economy will do
you think that will change in the future
as it seems that developing market are
leading the way out of the recession now
thank you thank you Stephanie please
yeah i'm stephanie with this jones that
work
I wanted to ask two questions if I may
one from Joe he very interestingly
pointed out how the financial markets
refused to fund government debt and
forced countries to follow deflationary
policies met in Greece I wonder I think
it's been very little thought about what
can be done about that and how these
financial markets has been rescued by
governments now refuse to fund
governments and I was only he had any
thoughts and how that perverse link
would be broken and I wanted to ask a
ticket Justin limb but also Alice
speakers um the the World Bank and the
Regional Development Bank seem to have a
lot of mechanisms and they've created a
lot of crisis acceleration facilities
but one looks at the disbursement that
have actually happened and also much the
commitments in the wake of the crisis
they have
Max and I was wondering what thoughts
been giving me how this could be changed
hi my name is Alex I'm a first year at
ciba as well you mentioned that the 30
years after the depression had some of
the most sustained growth without crises
and do is it naive to think that just
sort of increasing regulation and
restoring glass-steagall would be a way
to I guess you know circumvent the next
potential for a crisis and what do you
think the prospects are of that actually
happening ok right thank you very much
for those round that round of questions
let me now invite well I will probably
have to leave in a in a few minutes so
if I may just make a short intervention
and we'll ask Joe to preside over the
balance of the proceedings i would say i
would take the point which has been made
by several speakers and that's the whole
question of coordination and and and and
achieving a balance stimulus justin has
emphasized the point of excess capacity
one of the areas in which there is no
excess capacities in renewable energy
one of the problems of poverty is that
many people in the world are poor
because they actually have limited
access to poverty poverty are sorry to
energy and energy costs a great deal to
them one of the major areas in which you
could develop tremendous capacity where
there's no excess capacity is in
renewable energy generation the other
area of course is with food production
but one of the major problems standing
in the way of food production
particularly in developing countries has
been trade liberalisation because trade
liberalization has proceeded together
with huge production subsidies
particularly in the rich countries
that if we can find a way of addressing
those two issues simultaneously in other
words in the form of some kind of global
green new deal if you will we have we
have a good chance of of addressing two
of the major problems of our times
namely the challenge of climate change
as well as the as a food problem while
while contributing to to economic
recovery a balance balance economic
recovery that i would suggest remains
the major challenge it does not it's not
going to be achievable without the kind
of international solidarity and
cooperation which I think all of us
recognize to be part of the problem but
we really need that kind of of effort so
I want to thank the hymen Center for
having me here today and to thank the
panelists for the for the for the
interventions which have been all very
interesting and stimulating and invite
Joe Stiglitz to take over from and
preside over the session okay thank you
very much for coming and and let me just
ask Justin to to give response to
several of the questions that were
addressed towards you or Jenny the other
question comics on what any of the other
speakers have said well I just think too
you know because I think I see most of
the presentation and the argument you
have and as I that's just like the
responsible equation the first one is by
John regarding the excess capacity and
my argument for you know investment in
order to get out of this exit capacity
situation I think that it depends on
what kind of investment we are referring
to if we use that investment in a
manufacturing sectors then certainly it
may build up the capacity but as I
mentioned now the excess capacity is
many in the capital goods sectors in
high-income countries
and the investment I am arguing
basically infrastructure or energy
efficiency type of investment most kind
of us men you know we're not directed ed
up to the capacity in the capital
sectors but they were used the capital
goods for their investment and also
after they completed in general though
scanning infrastructure are not tradable
right if you have a highway system it's
not readable it may indirectly
contribute to export capacity because
efficiency improved but that's in direct
contribution but a centime if your
infrastructure and a sarong improve
transaction costs reduced efficiency
improve your expert increase by your
input will also increase so it's likely
to be balanced so you know that issue
has been taken to account in my proposal
and regarding the register just add and
under that I mean Prince is what I I
commented about the the need for
investments for organization is about
one percent of the population that moves
from the road to the urban sector the
urbanization in China is very high
density tall buildings use a lot of
steel so government investment to
provide housing for ordinary citizens
actually is a very heavy demander of
steel so that's an example of investment
that will actually use up the capacity
Richard and I'm regarding your question
in a Philippines irrigation
privatization of the irrigation and it's
likely impact in a song I'm not aware of
that project and if you know something
information will be happy to get that
and that too
still more and so maybe I'll be able to
respond no privately in that way
regarding in our the crisis facilities
and in his own from what I see the so I
seem to be quite responsive and we
cheaper that end in last year compared
to you know pre-crisis level and not
seem to work to some extent and
certainly there should be some room for
for the improvement but unless the in
terms of Adam it has been tripled I just
like to emphasize that you know that
when we think of the crisis we actually
are thinking in terms of the falling
output the unemployment and so on but
even before the crisis actually happened
in this form there was growing hunger in
the world there was growing malnutrition
in the world in other words it was this
particular crisis is superimposed or
something deeper and I think this is
linked to the whole question of
capitalism the issue is not just coming
out of this particular crisis the issue
is to come out of this crisis in a way
that does not accentuate hunger that
does not accentuate malnutrition that
does not in fact imply a further squeeze
as far as the consumption of the poorer
people in the world is concerned there
for the way of engineering if you like a
stimulus not only has to be co-ordinated
across countries but also has to take
the form in which that stimulus
simultaneously also gives rise to an
expansion in food production to a
revival of peasant agriculture and so on
I emphasize peasant agriculture because
you can have an increasing food
production even if you have corporate
farming but then the vast numbers of
people who wouldn't have the purchasing
power to buy the food which would be so
produced so it's extremely important
given the fact that the displaced
peasantry is not going to be absorbed in
the foreseeable future into any kind of
an expanding capitalist workforce it's
essential that I
truly the way of coming out of the way
of coming out of this crisis must be one
that actually sustains and supports
peasant agriculture and also raises food
production so that the basic problem of
hunger is overcome even as we come out
of the crisis I think that's where the
whole political issue is very important
because I think one of the main features
of contemporary capitalism is that it is
engaged in dispossessing small property
dispossessing small producers
dispossessing petty producers
dispossessing peasants and so on as you
know both in India and China there have
been very substantial numbers of clashes
where the peasantry has resisted
actually the disposition from land for
the purposes of industrialization zhan
so i think it's it's it's quite
important that the issue of capitalism
must be discussed in the context of an
entirely alternative routes trajectory
that would have to be a non capitalist
trajectory that actually respects the
position of the besan tree that that
actually protects them yeah let me just
make a couple comments the first is a
very general one about in a way the
crisis re showing some accept many of
the remarks here the the deficiency in
the way the market economy works I
emphasize more for the point that is
clearly not self-correcting not self
adjusting but there's another point that
comes out very clearly which is that
we've all identified a problem of excess
supply but we've also all identified
areas of huge demands where needs will
be put like that huge knees poverty
global warming food and somehow the
supply and demand is not equal abraded
in a way that's consistent with what we
think would reflect a well functioning
economy society and and the analytical
why that is seems to me a
a key issue of that that needs to be
thought about a lot more and a weight I
want to spend it just mention something
about the the financial system and
regulation is several the questions
relating that the first thing is to
realize the modern capitalism and
exemplified by what goes on in the
financial sector is rife with problems
of agency that is to say the people
making the decisions don't bear all the
consequences separation of ownership or
control people doing investing are doing
investing on behalf of others and
pervasive externalities problems in the
capital market in the financial markets
led to problems in the rest of the world
in west of our society and whenever that
occurs decision good decisions aren't
made and that's why you need regulation
to try to bring those a to bring those
better into a court but be recognizing
that they are not in court and will
never be brought perfectly into a court
prevent mitigate some of the adverse
consequences that will result and that's
why I think actually the general point
that is often raised we know regulation
was stifle innovation I think that's
wrong good regulation will actually
encourage good innovation the problem is
that the innovation that occurred was
induced not to solve society's problems
but to generate fees and actually did
not lead to any improvement in the
functioning of our economy so that's why
it's absolutely essential have stronger
regulation a question was should be a
reinstatement of glass-steagall will
that be enough well obviously can't
reinstate glass-steagall in the way that
it was 75 year
ago but that kind of separation is an
example of the kind of regulation that
we need Volkers talked about this
restrictions and proprietary trading
their whole set of restrictions I think
the Volcker rule did not go far enough
it was much but it would it identified
some of the couple of the problems and
was a move in the right direction but
there are still the problems of too big
to fail institutions credit default
swaps good regulation would I think had
the effect of directing the financial
sector in allocating capital more
efficiently better so if more of it
would be wind up in providing credit I
say two small medium-sized enterprises
rather than speculating against Greece
whether it would ever actually you know
the issue about financing particular
countries I think that's there's no easy
way of answering that question but
clearly if their attention was directed
more at lending as opposed to gambling I
think things would work better the one
of the questions was had to do with with
the locomotive for growth will the
developing countries continue to be will
the USB lokomotiva growth I the answer
for the immediate future is that we will
have to be looking for the emerging
markets as the ancient for global
economic growth I'm it really that that
I think the problems that I described in
the US Europe are sufficiently deep
seeded that one cannot expect that the
US or Europe to have robust growth I
hope I'm wrong for the next 2-3 years
perhaps longer last year i believe just
to make tell me fifty percent of the
growth was in China so of all the growth
that occurring in the world fifty
percent was in China is that I think
those are the numbers I saw recently the
final point I guess I want to remark
about the fact that that so often the
advice of the Guru's has been wrong
should induce a sense of modesty and
example was mentioned about agriculture
but of course the example the jomo
mentioned in the beginning of his talk
the IMF and the World Bank encouraged
capital market liberalisation financial
market deregulation the good thing was
that the World Bank moved away from that
position in the beginning of 1997 the
IMF has taken a lot longer to move away
from that position but I think the fact
that so many of the ideas that were
taken as conventional wisdom have now
been shown to be wrong is one of the
reasons why there should be should be
whether it is or not should be not only
a crisis and capitalism but there should
also be crisis in the economics
profession
well thank you very much and I want to
thank the speakers